[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia hoy repasamos las instancias
del poder político en siria a propósito
de las elecciones presidenciales de este
26 de mayo de 2021 unos comicios en un
país en guerra en donde su gobernante ha
masacrado a la población civil y la
oposición no tiene oportunidad alguna
dentro del régimen de acuerdo con la
constitución siria el periodo
presidencial es de siete años con lo
cual bashar al-assad está cumpliendo
tres mandatos presidenciales en damasco
y se apresta para un cuarto esto desde
que recibió en el año 2000 el poder tras
la muerte de su padre hafez la última
cita electoral de este tipo ocurrió en
2014 en plena guerra civil de siria que
había estallado desde la violenta
represión de bashar al-assad a los
manifestantes en el marco de las
protestas sociales por la primavera
árabe de 2011 al estar el país inmerso
en uno de los años más cruentos de su
guerra varias facciones de la oposición
boicotearon e impidieron la celebración
de los comicios en sus zonas de
influencia tal como lo hicieron
libre de siria y las milicias kurdas
gran parte de la comunidad internacional
en especial la onu criticó que dichas
elecciones se llevasen a cabo en medio
de una guerra que para la fecha había
cobrado la vida de 150.000 personas y
deslegitimaron un escrutinio
independiente en tales condiciones en
dichos comicios de 2014 se presentaron
por primera vez en 50 años varios
candidatos presidenciales en parte
gracias a los cambios en la constitución
promovidos por las protestas desde 2012
y como parte de su estrategia para
legitimarse en el poder el régimen de
bachar al-asad promovió un referendo
para aprobar una nueva constitución
multipartidista que aboliera el
monopolio histórico del partido baas
dicha constitución prometía que las
elecciones del 2014 serían directas y
con más de un candidato
en efecto 23 candidatos presidenciales
se registraron para competir contra al
asad de los cuales la corte
constitucional desestimó a 21 ya que no
cumplían con las reglas para ser
elegibles
entre las causales para ser descartado
como candidato estaba en la de ser un
opositor abierto al régimen de al asad y
haber vivido por fuera de siria en la
última década de manera que todos los
opositores que huyeron en medio de la
guerra no pudieron clasificar a dichas
elecciones y por tanto calificaron la
maniobra constitucional como una farsa
finalmente el 3 de junio de 2014 se
llevaron a cabo los comicios en los
cuales bashar al-assad reportó haber
arrasado con el 88.7 por ciento de los
votos sobre una participación del 73 por
ciento de los cerca de 16 millones de
habitantes inscritos para votar desde la
comunidad internacional los estados
árabes del golfo eeuu y la unión europea
desconocieron los resultados otros
países como brasil irán rusia y
venezuela aprobaron de manera conjunta
que la elección fue libre justa y
transparente antes de esos comicios de
2014 el escenario de elección era
distinto tanto en el 2007 como en el año
2000 el presidente fue elegido por
la vida de un referendo alentado por un
único partido el baaz de corte árabe y
socialista dicho partido fue concebido y
fundado en damasco a mediados del siglo
20 por los pensadores michel aflac y
xala albín al bitar la premisa de base
era combinar las creencias del
socialismo árabe el nacionalismo y el
panarabismo y hacerle contrapeso a la
oligarquía sin embargo su ascenso al
poder en siria sólo se dio hasta marzo
de 1963 luego de un golpe de estado
conseguido por un comité militar
denominado la revolución del 8 de marzo
fue el momento en el que el partido baas
tumbó por la vía de las armas al
gobierno que detentaba la élite
tradicional siria desde la independencia
de francia en 1946 entre los militares
que componían el comité que asestó el
golpe de estado en 1963 estaba hafez
al-assad un destacado militar que pronto
ascendió a ser el comandante en jefe del
ejército del aire- en 1960 y cinco años
más tarde al asad logró hacerse con el
control
del ejército paradójicamente tras la
derrota de la guerra de los seis días en
1967 y la fallida intervención en
jordania en 1970 a cargo del ejército
hafez al-assad propinó un nuevo golpe de
estado al forzar la dimisión del
presidente nuredín a la tasa que pese a
ser del mismo partido base era de
religión sunita contraria a la rama
alauita del chiísmo que profesaba al
asad luego de batallar contra los
dirigentes de su propio partido el 22 de
febrero de 1971 hafez al-assad se
autoproclamó presidente de siria y el
mes siguiente sometió su cargo a un
referendo que ganó con el 99.2 por
ciento de aprobación dos años más tarde
en 1973 al asad adelantó por la vía de
otro referendo la constitución que hasta
hoy rige al país en la cual siria se
considera una república socialista
democrática y popular pero no islámica
el artículo 8 de dicha constitución
consagró que el partido baas ostentaría
el mundo
del poder político en siria de manera
que por los casi 30 años que estuvo
hafez al-assad en el poder la oposición
fue perseguida y reprimida con violencia
así las cuentas con hafez al-assad de
1971 hasta el año 2000 y luego con su
hijo bachar del 2000 al 2021 son 50 años
de régimen en siria que incluyen una
guerra civil que ha dejado más de medio
millón de muertos 5.7 millones de
exiliados y 6.7 millones de desplazados
internos aun asi bachar al asad la
cabeza del violento y represivo régimen
sirio se plantea para un nuevo período
presidencial que lo siga perpetuando en
el poder así concluimos soy andrés
suárez jaramillo gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
[Música]